in this section you'll learn what
elastic load balancing is honestly load
balancing automatically distributes
incoming application traffic across
multiple Amazon ec2 instances it enables
you to achieve increased levels of fault
tolerance for your applications by
seamlessly providing the required amount
of load balancing capacity needed to
distribute the application traffic
you can distribute incoming traffic
across your ec2 instances in a single
availability zone or multiple
availability zones elastic load
balancing automatically scales its
request handling capacity in response to
incoming traffic
load-balancing can also detect the
health of your Amazon ec2 instances when
it detects an unhealthy instance it will
spread the load across the remaining
instances and no longer route traffic to
the unhealthy instance
when you're using VPC you can create and
manage security groups associated with
elastic load balancing to provide
additional networking and security
options you can also create a load
balancer without a public IP address so
it serves as an internal ie non internet
facing load balancer
elastic load balancing also supports the
ability to stick user sessions to
specific ec2 instances using cookies if
you remember from lesson two when we
talked about session affinity this is a
version of that
in this demonstration we're going to
create a load balancer for our sinful
zone web servers
you
so to do that we'll go to the
to section and I want to show you that
before we can configure load-balancing
there's a couple of things we need to do
so if we go to load balances on the left
hand side and then click on create load
balancer so we want to create the load
balancer inside simply learn VPC now I
want to show you this warning that comes
up says please select at least two
subnets in different availability zones
to provide high availability for your
load balancer you could think well it's
great we have two subnets we have a
public so I've met in a private subnet
and they're both in different
availability zones so if we add them
both we get another warning so this is
an internet facing elastic load balancer
but there is no internet gateway
attached to the subnet you've just
selected so obviously our private
gateway private subnet only has an at
gateway to provide its internet access
so it's not a public internet facing
subnet so what that means is we need to
create a new public subnet in a
different availability zone for our load
balancer so we already have this one
public in us east one B we're going to
create a public servant net in u.s. East
one C as well so to do that let's go
back to the networking VP c-section and
this is going to be a quick review of
the V PC lesson so I'll go to subnets
I'll sort by V PC so here are our two
existing subnets so we'll create a new
subnet and we're going to call it let me
just paste what I've copied we've got a
10.0.0.0 US east one c simply learn pub
and we're going to put it in our simply
learn vp c and we want to put it in the
US east one c availability zone so it's
different to our existing public subnet
and we're going to put it in that cidr
block
just click create so there we are now we
have
that's in our simple on bbc2 of them are
public now if you remember when you
create a new sudden that it will get
attached to your default route table by
default so that's no good because our
different route table doesn't have
internet access so we need to go to
route tables we click on our main
default route table and have a look at
subnet associations we can see that our
new subnet is in here so we need to move
it into our custom route table so it
will be the same as our existing public
subnet so if we click on edit
we just tick the box next to our new
public subnet and click Save so now our
new public subnet is in this route table
so it has internet access so now we're
good to go
so let's go back to the ec2 section and
we want to launch a new web server into
this new public subnet so we'll go to
what we'll launch it from our AMI
because we've already configured our web
servers as an AMI so we'll click Launch
which is teaching Nano or configure our
instance details so we're going to place
it in the simple env PC we're going to
place it in our new public subnet in the
US east one si availability zone we're
going to renew that a public IP we're
going to give it the administrator I am
role and we're going to protect against
accidental termination the storage is
fine
we're going to tag this one as simply
learn web server 3
we'll configure the security group so
we'll put it in an existing group which
will be the web service group and we'll
launch it using our existing simply
learned key pair which I have possession
of okay so that's launching so we can
see our simply learn web servers
so there we are they've got three of
them we've got one two which we're
already up and running and number three
which is coming online so now we're
ready to create our load balancing so
let's go to the load balancers again and
create load balancer we want to put it
in our V PC and we'll give it a name so
this is the kind of internal name we can
tag it differently later on because you
can't put any underscores or hyphens in
this section so call it simply learn LD
simply then V PC if you wanted to create
an internal load balancer so it was
balancing traffic that was just internal
to our AWS V PC we could tick this box
is the listener configuration so what we
can do here is we're saying that any
HTTP traffic that comes in on port 80 to
the load balancer that is being pushed
to pour HTTP 80 on our instances so what
we could do is you could change this you
could have a different port for the load
balancer and it maps it to your web
service you could protect your web
servers but we're just going to leave it
as it is now we want to add the subnets
so we're going to add both of our public
subnets and that warning is now gone so
now we're good we have two subnets into
availability zones next we assign
security groups so we could just use our
existing web server security group
because that has HTTP 480 open also has
HTTPS open and SSH so it's probably good
practice to create a new security group
just for our load balancer so I'll call
it simply then
load-balanced SG and we're simply going
to have HTTP port 80 open from anywhere
and nothing else I should probably just
give it a quick description so we know
what it is security group for load
balancing okay
so let's click Next configure security
settings and it's just telling us that
our load balance security isn't using a
secure listener because we're not using
HTTPS or SSL which is fine for this
demonstration
next we configure the health check so
this is to check that the load balancer
is going to perform the C of our
instances are healthy so it's using HTTP
port 80 and it's going to look for
existence of a file so we're going to
tell it to look for our health check dot
HTML file and if that doesn't exist then
the instance isn't healthy now we can
configure some more details so the
response timeout is 5 seconds we'll
leave that the interval between checks
the default value is 30 sets bring that
down because we want to one thing to
happen quicker so that's 10 seconds I'm
healthy threshold is set to 2 so if it
has two checks or it doesn't find the
file is going to determine that the
instance is unhealthy and the health and
fresh old is 10 we're also going to
bring that down we'll bring that down to
3 so after three consecutive healthy
checks it will say the instance is
healthy okay so now we can add our ec2
instances so we'll add our three web
servers we've enabled cross zone load
balancing so it can push traffic across
both availability zones and the
connection draining setting we'll just
leave as default that's when it detects
an unhealthy instance that's how long
before it will start redirecting traffic
elsewhere so next we'll click on add
tags so we can give this a more
meaningful name insulin underscore load
balancer and review and create ok so we
can review everything we did if you
should be ok so let's click create and
our load balancer is now being created
so let's have a look so here it is we
click on instances you can see the
instances and it's saying they're all
out of service at the moment so that's
because it's just configuring itself and
it will take a while to come up so I'm
going to pause the demonstration and
we'll come back when everything's up and
running okay so the load balancer has
configured and you can see that two of
our three web servers are in service but
our third web server is out of service
so why do you think this is well I'll
tell you why it's because our new web
server simply learn web server 3 has
just come up and we haven't done
anything to it other than just launched
the AMI so let's go and check out what's
going on on the instance so our local
concessions to our three web servers
here and this is the new one and it's
because the Apache Service
isn't started by default so we need to
start the Apache service okay so we got
that weird error but the it tells me
it's okay so if we now go back to the
load balancer and we wait a few seconds
we should see simply then web server
number three come online they wants an
hour online so it was as simple as just
starting the service so that shows how
load balancing works now if something
was out of service we could remove it
from the load balancer or we could go
investigate the problem or we could use
also scaling to manage it automatically
on our behalf and that's what we're
going to look at in the next
demonstration hey once become an expert
in cloud computing then subscribe to
simpler Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turner it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here